of a full head of red hair all right we
ready yeah hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and whenever you see
video of this podcast you know well G
whiz old freckles must have a special
guest well unfortunately that is not
true today uh my guest today is
astoundingly
mediocre um I've actually been ducking
this interview and he just kept calling
me
packing up and I just decided like you
know what let's just [__] get this
over with it's a rainy gloomy day what
more perfect weather to welcome my
wonderful guest Mr John litz everybody
John LoveIt John wake up buddy buddy hey
there we
go got to get some of this 5H Hour
Energy to stay awake for this thing why
are you so mean to me by the way did you
hear your intro why can't you just admit
how much you like me I like you very
much you bustonian bastard yeah you're
always like coming at me I like how
you're dressed I like you you have a
little flare there in your collar this
is Robert Graham the shirt and the thing
mhm who are you wearing Robert Graham
Robert Graham oh I just said that is is
that a Macy's line how's the listening
techniques coming along are you a
Nordstrom's
guy no no but you know what what my one
of my best friends used to date a
guy that his mother was a
Nordstrom oh was part of that family yes
like directly like all of his uncles own
it oh so this guy he was like turns out
no he was a very nice guy no but she no
my friend was L and I met the guy and I
go he's gay she goes no he's
not and then three years they break up
and it turns out that he's gay is a very
nice guy and he texted
me but anyway I he he said you knew
before me you said you said the guy was
dating a guy at Nordstrom no let me no
no my friend is a woman and she was one
of my best a woman she was dating a guy
whose family owns Nordstrom oh and at
one point when I first met him I said
you know he's that guy he's very nice
but he's gay she goes no he's not I go
you yeah he yeah so anyway at one point
she say was gay did he put his hand
because you couldn't because anyway she
my friend said was he just walking
around end up breaking up no it was very
obvious so then she says she goes no he
has a kid and this so then she says to
me how did you know he was gay what was
your first clue I go
him and he even asked me he goes how did
you knew before I
knew that's bizarre I understand being
in brought Nordstrom
well I didn't think that that was going
to turn into some Lifetime movie about
coming out to a yeah you did you knew
exactly what you were doing I knew I was
going to pull it you know I don't think
people know that we you know we're we're
we met through um dating app Randy
w r yeah Randy Waldman who was a great
piano player and also your helicopter
instructor yes instructor and I just got
off the phone and did you know I don't
know if you know this but whenever Randy
uh flies with you he makes out a new
will right before that wouldn't surprise
me it wouldn't surprise he always has
his hands near the controls when I'm on
him um no he's actually excuse me
tuberculosis he's um actually uh as good
a helicopter pilot as he is a a Pianist
and he was he was a prodigy piano player
his first gig was with Frank Sinatra
yeah and now he's he's doing shows with
me I don't know if you know that I I
know you didn't you didn't show up what
do you had a you had a you call no you
call me like last second to tell me that
you're singing your jokes at a at a
Panera Bread place or something April
18th I'll be at vibr oh vibr jazz club
can you can you sing us a joke or
something that you're doing maybe yes
sure
billberg likes it in the
bu
gently when you squeeze his left nut out
the blood
flows out of his butt wherever he goes
you know you're going to open with that
no that that feels like a middle of the
set you're the you're the one who's
opening
oh I see where you no but I I have a
question for you Cu uh you'll notice
this very quickly in this uh in this uh
podcast that I have a severe ADD my
after 7 Seconds my brain goes off on
tangents now to be a I'm like really
trying to trying like you're Robin
Williams and you just can't no I'm not
but it's true yes you are not never and
I've been waiting for years for you to
finally admit that the way you carry
yourself with the pompous [__] I'm not
Robin Williams but I knew him very nice
guy and I made him laugh unlike you my
question is this is a compliment to you
what how do you stay so focused being
you have to be being a helicopter pilot
mhm it to me I'm it's being sincere now
yes oh and it's killing me but it's
impressive that you're a helicopter
pilot isn't that way harder than flying
a plane and aren't there like a million
things to do at once how do you do it
well I've never flown a plane so I I
don't know all I can say is if I can
learn how to do it then anybody can
learn how and I actually thought my
biggest fear was not learning how to fly
it it was ground school and the te test
and cuz you know I did not do well in
school so I didn't think uh but I also
surprise you know John whenever you lash
out at me like that it's I just know
it's all self-loathing okay and you can
come in here with your Tony Curtis
haircut and act like you're you're just
the bees knees and I just don't buy it
Tony Curtis there's another guy there's
another guy that went to Nordstrom that
I have hair and you don't H like it's my
fault no there's just something about
the I didn't give you my
jeans I have nothing to do with
it
why are you so I actually had a good
idea for you Jesus you know how you play
why do you yell at the beginning of your
sentences is that to shut get excited
get excited
um I think did you lose you should have
me open for you you're playing Arenas
now but I think with me you could be
playing
stadiums okay I'll bring you on the road
yeah but you have to pay
me well I
over I understand that you want to go on
the road with me is that what you want
John is that what this is is all about
that's not what this is about but yeah I
would like to I've never played an
arena well you've been keep looking at
your fa you're aging naturally your
camera they go the camera adds 15 PBS
your camera is adding like a hundred no
off camera this is doesn't even exist
you know there's a lot of women that are
into that it's a fetish they call them
uh
Pelos you like furries they're ring
people with uh son of a a [__] bastard
no your face has you forward your face
has its own neck
pillow it must be nice when you get on a
plane like this your neck fat just kind
of catches you
before I know it's true and it's said I
don't know where this came from I really
don't I'm thinking maybe it's because I
eat too much but I highly doubt it it's
just I just think I breathed in really
hard once and too much air and it went
and then it just stopped Dizzy Gillespie
had a neck like that but it was cuz he
played the trumpet and changed music
that was his cheeks you you on the other
hand have have that because you eat cake
at
night no
pastries salt Peanuts salt peanuts
um this is basically you're one of my
favorite people in this business because
this is all we do is we just give each
other [__] and I have been having a
field day with you know the G never done
it it's always on the I've been having a
field day texting
you annoying things about the guysa well
let's just call this episode the Jew and
the Nazi let's just get down to it we do
it in text we've never done it face to
face just I'm just presenting and I told
you I'm bringing my hoarder oh God boom
go ahead no I just mentioned let the
games begin we like to discuss World
politics and way ways to solve them or
possible sources for the conflict you
know I like I have to be honest with you
I never had a problem with Jews until I
met you and then I was like ah now I get
it every other really Jewish person I
met was they were nice they were very
family oriented and you just walking
around like this Bond villain with your
little
dog how old is that [__] dog I mean
you can't leave it alone when is it
going to grow up and get a driver's
license he's in good shape he's 13 his
dog is in great shape yeah his name is
Jerry brookheimer
III yes that's his actual name I know
unlike you I'm actually friends with the
real Jerry bimer oh I love when you
throw your Show Business friends in my
face what was uh what was gav you know
the way we what was Gavin M cloud
like he was like you bald when
you when you did the loveboat yeah let's
go back okay before you had The Chins
okay and you look good in Bermuda shorts
okay don't do that don't make the sad
face you know what I'm just going to
tell you this true story I did a movie
Once I Was an extra and the lead actor
said you know what can you do this
little bit and I did it and he goes you
could have a career in in comedy and
this was years ago this guy was at his
Peak his name was Charlie
Chaplain you whoever said you were
good
Tick
Tock you actually were great you were
great in
um the Pete Davidson movie mhm every
once in a while like the king of Staten
Island king of Staten Island no I'm
being sincere that's why I for you were
so great you were you were you started I
didn't even know you weren't fun you
weren't funny you weren't trying to be
funny it was a drama but you were so
great that I didn't know it was you and
I kept going wait is that bill no that's
not bill is that it is but in and you
look 15 years older in the movie than
you do in
person can you please explain that one
well no really you look like I can't
just get a [__] can you answer the
question you have a lot of Regis fil
when yell the beginning of the sentence
do
I what's the answer um come
on I think you were confused because it
was actually good and your your your
thoughts of me is that I'm horrible and
I know you joke around about it a lot
but I know that that's coming from
someplace well deep down deep down you
are
horrible I this is your whole act Albert
Einstein's a genius what do you think
Bill um I I don't is he is he is really
really he couldn't even get a decent
haircut what's that his mustache he
couldn't trim it the guy who had ad he
was just you know he how'd you come up
with your stuff Albert oh I sit on the
couch and think for 20 minutes ooh
that's so hard I'm going to do your
[__] act go
ahead why the chicken cross the
road to get to that cookie on the side
how and the [__] band kicks in that's
what you do you f louer can't say oh you
wake up in the morning and you brush
your teeth Bill bur takes it up the butt
you wake up in the morning and you brush
your hair
bber takes it up the butt it's as easy
as 1 2 3 simple as
ABC you wake up in the morning and you
take a breath of air Bill Bird takes it
up the butt up the butt up the butt up
the
butt that's my ACT hey you know what I
have an idea for a movie for you I know
you're looking for a
project I he it all right you reboot
Kung Fu Panda all right you're playing
the panda just stay with me all right
right and you still have martial artarts
but because it's you you call it JW
Jitsu and it's just about you in a bear
suit that that joke kicking the [__] you
have a yamaka just let me let me flesh
it out go ahead all right we're not even
on page 10 I'm not even giv you the
motivation right all right you're a
furry you know you meet some chick she
dresses like uh you know Yogi Bear and
you guys
bang and then somewhere in there there's
something about the Federal Reserve I
haven't I haven't worked out the second
in third act yet but just wondering what
you think about that I like it to be
honest I think it's very good you're
very you Beverly
D'Angelo and uh maybe we can get one of
those young pop stars in there to now I
have a movie idea for you no Jesus um
you you're in America and you're
watching the news and you go I this
Hamas I got to help him you
go over there go fellas fellas get out
of the [__] tunnels come on you're
losing let's let's try something I have
a secret strategy that'll work oh it's
like that soccer show that wins all the
Emmys all the time what's that what's
that Ted lasso it's like Ted lasso meets
Hamas that's how you sell it yes yeah
Ted amas yes all right but your name
isn't Ted lasso what could it
be Bill
Hitler something like that that's just
off the top of my head Inc like your
head
[Laughter]
and your
turn I don't want to no I know did you
ever see Steve Martin and Martin Short
show the first although there's a murder
in in the apartment no no they're they
live show it's really funny but no every
time the first 20 minutes this is what
they do they go you know Hollywood
compliment when you're saying something
nice but not it's a backhanded and they
just rip each other for 20 minutes like
this and it's hilarious like you know I
love your shirt do they make that in men
friend you know GE you know you say
someone what a lovely dress do they have
it in your size you know yes they're
just completely could you give me some
more examples cuz I didn't understand it
the first [__] nine times Bill your
act is so funny I forgot to
laugh you know I don't know who forgot
to put the ice packs under your [__]
eyes today but like I'm really getting
tired of looking at that puss what do
you think about
that well you know what you look you
know what speaking of how is yours
coming along because I understand you
really transitioned and I think it's
great you know what they do chop your
dick off and punch a hole and you go I'm
good to go and then you go home to your
wife she's like well she goes bill I
don't know what to say but you chopped
your dick off but it looks bigger than
ever
bill has a penis and now it's an
innie
this is just your dysfunctional way of
saying that you like me yeah it is you
know why are you so guarded with you I
just want to say something I think
transgender say something you haven't
shut the [__] up for 20 minutes singing
pitching okay you want I thought this
was going to be a dialogue all right go
ahead no I'm I'm you go ahead it's not
how you start a conversation how long
have you lived
alone um that's why you have a dog the
thing can't [__] interrupt you that's
right
do you squeeze
it do you squeeze your
dog sometimes a little too
vigorously when you have a bad set you
come home and you just [__] you hear
it Yelps a little bit and you get this
sense of power that you don't feel you
have in the rest of your life is that
what
happens and you go into the bathroom and
there's no more conditioner left and you
blame the
dog
do you you wanted me to
listen and look how the real you the
ugliness spews forth from the bowels of
your
brain my God what are you talking about
you've been like ridiculously rude
you've interrupted you're
shouting I'm not shouting and you're
just do you want me to just
say you didn't even dress up you came in
here I this is dress up you look like
you were on your way to the dry cleaners
you're like oh [__] I got to do a
podcast this is designer clothing for
you and this this shirt and this jacket
are from the same designer do you have a
deal do you have a clothing line or
anything I want one yeah would I like it
Robert Graham Robert Graham beautiful
men's clothes John loveit's collection
well wouldn't get rid maybe I wouldn't
have a big cardboard cut out of you
second floor Nordstroms looking over
your
[Laughter]
shoulder
it's funny Bermuda shorts and just you
sort of bring it back you know I could
go directly to the issues with your
father the dentist but I think that's
below the Bel go ahead I'll talk about
your dad who built a hospital and then
had you yeah didn't do much who didn't
do much of anything all right go ahead
your dad's a dentist did he forget to
teach you how to floss Jesus Christ your
breath is so bad my dog's throwing up
and he's sitting down there on the floor
and your
turn
I love thee and your
turn and scen I heard your dad didn't
die of natural causes I already saw your
act and went home and killed
himself so he wouldn't have to see the
second show and back to
you go ahead be meaner you know you got
it in
you oh he's
thinking well um no I don't want to be
mean I just I understand you because
it's hard having a father who doesn't
really like love
you just thinks of you as you know
baggage and all right all right I mean
my dad I have a twin sister I was born
second my dad called me
placenta he was joking but he wasn't
yeah but it's good to grow up without
love what did your dad call you bow
movement
Bill BB by the way what your first name
is Wilbur so when you no it's William
you [__] no it isn't it's Wilbur you
you were Wilber
Wilber what's your first name
Jacob Jonathan you changed your first
name so you could work in Show Business
he didn't change loveits let I'm saying
you're dumb that why didn't you change
your name to John O loveits maybe like
David O sells they used to do maybe can
sell some tickets in the red
States John O LoveIt coming to
Texas they love me I like that John love
it do you know the movie producer that
did Gone With the Wind David selnik and
he did that he changed his name to David
O snik he did exactly that I know David
kep the Snick and anti-semites are so
[__] stupid that probably worked did
work what do you feel about the news I
don't watch it I find it
astoundingly uh
depressing and uh you know I saw
something stupid comment they go there's
no hate speech this speech you hate they
these [__] I feel like it's their
only Power that they have is to just be
[__] mean and not understanding of
other people well you know it's the I
have to and then they always like [__]
your feelings and everything there's
some of the most sensitive [__]
people put on a mask I can't
breathe I thought I was doing a podcast
I didn't know it's coming to a comedy
show what are you talking I'm just okay
I'm trying to answer you know maybe if
you sold some more tickets you could for
afford a hood on your
sweatshirt I was going to give you a
compliment oh you don't know how to do
that no you I saw you on Joe Rogan and
you were talking about the corona uh
coronon virus yeah the corona isn't that
a beer what is it then yeah that's what
they called it is it Corona yeah it's
you got to it was Co it is they also
called it the Corona virus from they
called the Red Red Bull the Red Bull you
were sitting there with your you know be
trying to be all you know hip but not
really but trying hard but acting like
you're not trying hard with your cigar
go and you go you know I'm not going to
sit here with you and I Joe I've known I
love Joe and I think he's very I I get
you're G to trash me just get on to no
I'm not trashing Joe you just said I'm
not going to sit here with no medic
we're not going to sit here no medical
degree and say what's the cause of and
cure of Co do you remember
that finally he's admitting that he's an
idiot
it'sing but right but you're right but
that's that's the news and social media
everyone's got an opinion and so they
all think they're Geniuses and so
there's a lot of disinformation out
there for example I've seen a lot of
tweets about you oh he's so funny he's
so funny you've got to see his show he's
hilarious and I'm like thisinformation
is incorrect and maybe I should say like
thisinformation ain't right but that's
what it's you know disinformation is
incorrect mhm yeah no there's a lot of
uh that'll get letters there's a lot of
[__] there's a lot of I I just yeah I
just sort of like I I tap
out
what why are you drinking that [__] to
wake me up I don't sleep good I had to
get up at 8 this morning and like 8 I oh
God I went to bed at 10:00 I kept waking
up it's so early I know but that's like
liquid cocaine and a man in your shape
yeah so what how much blow did you do
back in the day
I didn't do
any I didn't need first of all was
remember the basketball player Len Bias
cocaine for you was powdered sugar right
pie on top of your chocolate I got
Saturday Night Live I gain 10 pounds
every year for five years and it's still
there tell me tell me this here is cake
from 85 I haven't been able tell people
what Lauren said to you when you kept
putting on weight what did he say to you
um we don't need another fat guy oh John
we already have a fat person a fat guy
fat guy but we they didn't have a fat
guy or maybe he meant Chris Farley but
um I never uh I never did that stuff
remember Len B the basketball player he
supposed to be he was going to be like
LeBron James or uh how could LeBron
James LeBron James wasn't around yet no
he was going to be like the next he
would have been giant thing in the NBA
we were finally going to get and he was
23 did cocaine and he had a heart attack
and died there go was the first time did
it I don't know but it scared the crap
out of me I don't think the first time
you you try cocaine you free base it I
have no idea but that uh it was a real
tragedy Bill I know the Celtics drafted
him I was [__] living in the state at
the time scared the [__] out of me we
actually [__] agree and you're still
yelling at
me don't stare at me like I'm all of a
you know what this why you trying to
make me cry classic abuse you don't have
that emotion you're not you're not you
don't have access to that you know when
you cry you know when you cry it's not
my fault you went bald I had nothing to
do with it let blame somebody else
listen if you think your hair system is
fooling anybody you've had that [__]
receding hairline for 40 years and it
hasn't moved you took the back off of
your your hair off your back and you
stuck it on your head and now you're
sitting acting like you're better than
me you're not you're not I am hey ball
Don't Lie the ball don't lie right you
can keep say that to your yourself all
day long but the fact is deep in your
heart we both know I am better than you
can you please pop your you going to
start
crying what's it like having someone sit
across from you and you go my god I've
met my match I I rip people all the time
on stage they laugh but this guy comes
back like a [__] Howitzer there's
nothing I can say that he doesn't have
comeback boom boom boom you're like oh
my God I thought it was just me just me
just me well it
ain't are you [__] writing your own
good review
here I didn't I mean I knew we I'm nice
back and forth I didn't realize it was
so one-sided what do you mean I'm saying
you're hysterical but I'm saying I'm
coming you're I'm coming back at you and
you don't know what to do so you go to
the bottom the butt the pit the depth
the nuts the below the the belt what are
you talking about you've been singing
about me taking it in the ass like from
the beginning you immediately went
bodily fluid jokes don't actually I said
what that you what don't act like you're
[__] you have a higher brow [__]
comedy than I do Sor I said that I I
would never say that I'm say you look
like an extra in Casino EXT we need
someone who look like a degenerate we
need to have somebody that looks like
they've never won in their life I know
John Lovitz should we give him some
lines we don't want him to act we want
this picture to make money here's an
idea stick them in the back shut your
face stick them in the movie for you
know what your nose makes your face very
aerodynamic is that that's a good one
yeah do you stick your head out the
window like Ace have an idea for a movie
for you you go you go to a school you're
a teacher a school for the deaf and they
all gather outside right and then you go
to teach him you go hi Mr Burr I'm going
to I'm going to teach you right and then
they go what are you doing they're
[__] deaf and you go oh sorry and you
go any and you start doing sign language
and then all of a sudden the Sun comes
out from behind a cloud and it bounces
off your head and it blinds them now
they're deaf and blind cuz it's a Sheen
off of your head called It's called The
Helen
Kellers and then what happens is Jack
Black comes in and teaches him to play
guitar and that's the happy ending that
everybody wants I'm going to go I didn't
want to go here but now I am because
you're going oh your nose your nose okay
what's with this [__] a be mole right
here on your head what's that bum it's
precancerous is a cancer but it's too
close to my brain so they can't remove
it fingers closed you know I'll tell you
what that is I'm going to tell you the
truth about that thing and I know the
truth I'm going to talk about your
[__] airbags a do and you said Doctor
what is this thing on my head the
dermatologist says I don't know you
better go to a specialist so you went to
a German dermatologist and he goes oh
that thing on your head is going to
become a full grown penis and he said
does and he said cuz that's where he's
from and
so so and you and you Bill bur said doc
what are you saying I'm going to walk
around the rest of my life seeing a dick
hanging in front of my eyes and he says
no you'll never see it and you go why
not you goes because your balls will be
covering your eyes and that's what that
is can I ask you a question does your
right eye get more sleep than your left
eye why is the bag under your left eye
so much bigger than the right eye
[Laughter]
I mean yeah which one's better that one
that one has it's it's [__] gigantic
this is what I look like I used to look
like this all
right oh don't I look like 20 years
younger why don't why don't you let's
check this out that's
amazing oh wow check here I can l so why
don't you just get some tape you do like
you do the movie of your life first
think of it's called plexaderm oh you
were talking sorry nobody wants to play
you in Hollywood
so you have to play yourself so we just
get some tape okay and this is Young
John loveits we keep your hair salt and
pepper right we just and we just bring
it back down for the closing number in
the end and um we'll give your character
cancer and you'll get nominated you know
am I supposed to be looking into your
eyes or looking at this thing because
it's becoming another head all right
well once you vacuum up the room with
your [__] nose how about that you son
of a [__] yeah why don't you you got a
big shark nose do they close the beach
when you lay on your back huh you want
to go old school here oh you want to go
down that town down that street down
down that town huh you want to go down
that street all right I'll do that with
your fleece
Overcoat stop staring at me like you
know how to fight although you've had a
couple of scraps in your life haven't
you oh yeah look you got your fist all
balled up huh you ready to
go good thing you pulled your hand away
because I almost killed you I don't want
you have that eczema or whatever on your
[__]
knuckles
is that from jerking off in Alaska no
you [__] wad it's
psoriasis you have psoriasis I can't say
much that just made me happy and you
have alipa so what's the
difference yeah now we're equal I'd
rather I can take medicine to get rid of
this you why don't you that hair ain't
selling enough [__] tickets without
surgery I could go out and I could have
gone out and got a [__] hair system
like you and sit across like some
retired show host this is all natural I
don't know what you're talking about I
know let me ask you this
question wait a minute do you feel any
guilt with a [__] hair system
trashing somebody that's like somebody
with fake titties making fun of some
flat chest oh after what you said about
my nose and the fat under my chin no I
don't feel any guilt I feel great all
right now let me ask you this how did
you go this is a real question okay when
you're playing a club right or or you
used to but you remember now you're
playing or theater and then you play
Arenas do you have to change your like
in an arena like you're timing as if you
in a say like an improv Club is it would
you have to do anything different and if
so what
no no the sound the sound systems are
amazing now so you you don't have to do
that it's not like back in the day when
they used to bounce off the back and
then come at you you don't really yeah
well I mean I don't know why you need
this information you're never going to
play an arena no [__] that's why I want
you to open for you so I could I did it
I'll have you I'll have you I was at
Madison Square Garden it wasn't me I was
I was that a Nicks game bill yeah there
no Paul Simon was raising money for a a
short people like a blue a bus for like
more like an ambulance to go to help
people in the in the in New York City
you know they have enough or just your
people no okay African-American people
okay I was just making sure
85 so they had a big concert it was
called Big Blue I think at at Madison
Square Garden it's called the ambulance
going to and then I I was in it and I
got on stage doing my liar character my
very famous bit and uh this was like an
and and I was just I'd never been on a
stage you know I'd seen bands but i'
never been on the stage it was you know
Madison Square guard was like 19,000
people and I think when you did it it
was like 18,000 this was 19,000 and it
was like amazing
that is so [__] Petty it was so it
was so you want to hear Petty there was
a [__] comedian one time he goes like
you know I did it in the round these
other guys are doing it like [__]
they got the stage BL you to [__] say
that it was so [__] Petty I hate the
I did went showing the round I think
it's the stupid it's maybe it's good for
a music I like it it's you do yeah uh
but then your back's always to somebody
it's like
ridiculous yeah but it also it makes it
way more in
well what do you do do you draw a little
face on the back of your head and get
like lips a little mechanical lips and
blah blah blah blah so that I hate it I
think it's list just because stupidest
idea ever for a stage listen just
because you're limited as a performer
doesn't mean you have to keep attacking
my looks I've never why don't they do
why don't they do a stage where like
it's you know everybody's in the arena
and the stage is outside in the parking
lot why don't they do that yeah I don't
even know what that means well I'm just
saying it's a dumb idea why don't you
stop doing this every time I'm talking
I've noticed you do that what you start
going
up you start revving the engine of your
voice oh cuz I get an idea oh I know and
then I get all excited can I ask you a
question sweetheart why would you rather
bored why are you gay I don't
know why are you
here is there your producer invited me I
no you [__] asked me no you asked me
for years
years am I doing your podcast what am I
doing my podcast what I doing and then
you come in
here and you were just bringing this
rude energy that you know I do not
appreciate where's the warmth where's
the guy um when I watched your VHS tape
that your agent sent your agent sent me
that your agent sent me and I popped
that into one of the last VCRs in Los
Angeles and I watched your your set at
that Elks Club I saw a a young
man with one chin that was warm and
respectful to his audience and then you
come in this [__] Abomination yeah
let me just say something to you right
behind you is a sign it says all things
comedy what are you doing can you start
being funny because I have to 5 Hour
Energy to keep myself awake to listening
to your crap you know what I let's let's
be honest bill goes oh we both had
fathers that were not nice let's put it
like that like really so I go bill I
have a book for you help distract the
verbally abusive relationship it might
help you and what did Bill get out of it
now John I have new ways to abuse you
thanks for the
book oh that [__] I mean they had
there was like that was like a
Highlights
magazine like self-help book I actually
lost a lot of respect for your intellect
when you sent me that book it's like did
he buy this at the
airport have seen people buy books you I
don't know if you're trying to be funny
right now now being serious I can't tell
but you're really hurting my feelings
not because you can say whatever you
want but I'm probably 10 years older
than you so probably I have more
experience I've have 10 years more you
what
failing [__] I think if people are going
to listen to this they're going to go
bill one bill one no they're not they're
going to be this is like when my wife
comes on she trashes me they love it and
I I'm enjoying it I'm actually enjoying
your pathetic attempts to try and hurt
me we're watching all things
comedy this show is not
funny and I'm a great setup I'm funny
but you are listen John you're very you
know something the number one way the
difference between you and me is this no
I'm I'm going to interrupt this is a
difference you're funny you're funny
you're very funny but you're a comic I'm
a comedian see you say funny things I
say things funny I can say anything and
make it funny okay can you no I can't
I'm going to give you the word I'm going
to spell it out let's see you you give
me an example I want to see how I'm
going to spell out the word just one
word and let's see if you can make it
funny cuz I can h e i I even can spell
it out and be funny just do it h e l l
o oh God what's the word it's John L you
go hello
thank you that's how you do it yeah yes
hello yeah and it's funny now let you do
it you know what you have you have
nextdoor neighbor on a sitcom level
chops say the word n o no say the word
no make it funny
go Tick Tock times
up now I'll
go
no and I'm
laughing John I don't understand you
nobody does I like you I don't
understand me
either so do you have anything to
promote or did you just come in here to
rip me a new oh I didn't know if I could
well you did by the way I mean you
[__] destroying me and I hav I I
didn't really I didn't even get started
talking all right believe me no I got
plenty more in the tank all
relax my second show is going to be
completely
different oh I'm doing this again what
what are we doing you're supposed to do
a series of this you're supposed to come
on here this is the first one we rip
each other the second one is we're like
really nice then the third one is we're
back to ripping each other and then the
fourth one is you just rip yourself like
you do every morning anyway with your
own
thumb now um what's oh I want to PL how
do you I don't want to plug you nice
try can you just promote something to
make this worth while in well I'm at the
Laugh Factory in in Vegas and uh that's
at the Tropicana hotel but they're
they're uh tearing down the that
hotel lasted 70 years until they booked
you and now they're tearing it down I
mean it was a class they have that
beautiful that glass ceiling that what
is it they don't take care of that hotel
the people that work there are very nice
but the even the people that work there
they go yeah they they don't once they
said it they go yeah they sto vacuuming
they don't care they don't take care of
the people that stay there and that's
why they booked you there like this is
what they're giving you I can't imagine
what the buffet is on my phone on me
they have an amazing room on the 20th
floor huge Suite amazing views oh that's
and that was horrible you could I'm on
on Las Vegas pull ofart
and I look out and there's a big
billboard of mg and then you kept
popping up on it Bill bur at the at the
uh Park what was it I don't park MGM
Park MGM over and over every 10 seconds
boom there's your face boom there's your
face boom there's your
face I never I had to go to the hospital
you were texting I got so sick you were
texting me you know I I think it's great
I actually am very supportive uh I think
it's amazing that you or any other
comedian Joe Koy used to open for me
playing Arenas there used to be there
was Steve Martin and then there was like
Andrew Dice Clay and then I don't know
and then D I love Jo
and everyone's there's like 10 of them
CA the agency they dropped me they go we
only want Arena act I go well what is it
there's seven and then they I said they
go no he said we only want renal renal X
like Bill re rectum renal how bad did
Joe Koy get [__] on that award show
they gave the guy 10 [__] days to
come up with that and then everybody's
like ripping him and and that actress
called him an [__] and stuff it was
just like it's a comic I was just going
like like who hasn't been there
it ended up being like a bad corporate
gig you know what I mean like they make
just make jokes about
ourselves well the yeah I mean some of
his jokes were really F it's weird if
you he's a [__] great comic I worked
with that guy a long time ago he's
ridiculously ridiculously talented and
then they they he used to open for me
and a lot of people did and then they
moved on no and then I said he got so
your I said I follow you now I could
follow him easy but then I couldn't but
he's a great comedian no he used to open
for me for a year and a half now what
does that mean it's not like you when
you're backstage and you say to your
that you're opening at you can you open
for
me you're in your Dre room and is it
true you were a body double for Al
Gore is it is it true oh God that
you you were um Jewish and then you tell
everyone you're not so they because
you're just puss oh come
on Bill
burwitz yeah I found out I did a deep
dive on Wikipedia yeah your nose job is
great bill John is it true that your
last dog killed itself cuz it got so
sick of the
loneliness is it true that your children
want to change their last name to love
its because they want to be associated
with a comedian that's actually funny
and your wife is it true that you
haven't bought clothes since
no is it true that you have a giant
cheese ball on the crack of your ass
right now and you go leave it I want it
to
grow is that true that one reflected
more on you than it did on me did
yeah but you're everything you're saying
is about you and then you're just
pinning it on me so go
is it true that after the Tropicana
closes they're going to bring you to
Treasure Island and then they'll quickly
tear that one down
too are you doing the John love it kills
what's left of the uh Vegas strip
tour is it true that they put you at the
park
MGM because that was the only place
where they had a toilet wide enough for
your [__] ass butt [__] dick [__]
is it true you got fired from the Paris
because your nose made the Eiffel Tower
look too
[Laughter]
small is it true you just got cancelled
by the Anti-Defamation League because
you're hiding your anti-Semitism behind
jokes and now you know anti I mean I can
still sell
tickets nobody gets cancelled you get
demoted is it true that oh you're quit
twiddling your thumbs what's the real
issue here if you could go back and
change one thing in your life John we're
going to end with some questions I would
make my penis smaller because it's so
big that
women they call it the anchor it's I've
split many women and I don't mean to and
it's just it's a it's it's sad yeah next
question
all right uh hey I have a question your
your favorite gig you've ever
done oh we're being
serious sorry I would say the most fun
although I had of course you didn't was
a Saturday Night Live live television is
the best now I had a great time on well
if you're going to go on there and do a
monologue like that bill I mean oh
God I mean I've I've heard I never heard
more silence than you know in my life I
mean I thought you were funny but
clearly the audience didn't and as you
pointed out I'm an idiot
so SNL was your favorite gig yeah I mean
it was it was really hard it was Kevin
nean said it once he goes every week
your highest highs and your lowest lows
because you you you would go to you know
I couldn't believe I was there the whole
time I was on there I'm sure you
couldn't yeah I
know no I couldn't even say Saturday
Night Live the whole I'm on Saturday
night law I couldn't literally I
couldn't believe I was there did your
dad ever show up and actually he did
come to a show and then at the end he
was I looked at him and he was like he
was beaming which made me feel great cuz
that was the whole point you know trying
to make him happy what a waste of time
but he was happy that night he was happy
that night that's great and I was
thrilled you know and I just to see him
smile like that was
fantastic it would be like can you
imagine that you're on stage and anybody
in your family
or your wife anybody and you finish and
their crowds on their feet cheering and
they're looking at you and they're not
frowning but smiling can you right you
but no and that's that's why I'm your
friend no my family's been very
supportive yeah right listen John not
everybody because you pay you give them
money that's why they're supportive John
not everybody you're a narcissist not
every but just because you grew up that
way doesn't mean everybody did you know
I've had issues yeah but you did
we've talked about it don't don't start
with
me but you're acting like my whole
family I it wasn't my whole family all
right they just relax with that and stop
[__] leaning forward like oh look at
you look at you I I touched the nerve no
no no I don't mind if you you trash my
my dad that doesn't bug me but I mean
you can't take everybody else out
everybody else was [__] cool were
they oh you just went a little Law and
Order there were they were they I don't
know about that were they were they yeah
I don't know about that I'm doing you
back to
you were they were
they oh John you know I don't think
people the one thing I've said that you
actually got offensive of but you can
make fun about I got off a Jewish nose
you're no I never said you had a Jewish
nose said you have you John love it I'm
proud you John love I am what I am I
don't you know I didn't have a choice
about it look you went after the mole
it's the biggest thing on my face and I
had to go I had to go back with the
biggest thing on you I went up to the
mole because you went after everything
you you talk about trying to look you in
the eye all I see is a tip of your nose
it's like a [__] oil tankers coming
into Port oh your family doesn't love
you you know what Leonardo DiCaprio
should be standing on the bridge of your
[__] nose going like that the only
reason your family was supportive
because they were hoping once you played
Arena a you'd give them a bunch of
money oh you [__] bastard now dry
your tears and get the [__] out I'm
taking over welcome to All Things comedy
with I'm glad your blood sugars through
the roof why don't you ask me another
question I you know what when are you
going to lose your first toe from that
disease when are you going to get wart
medicine and just take this thing off
right here well not I another year you
won't be able to see out of that eye
that way that thing's
growing do you wear a one piece bathing
suit because you're ashamed of your
torso
yes don't do that that's not fair suris
you can't come on you you can't have
feelings go to the
beach Shir pants and you wear sleeves
it's like you have leprosy and everyone
makes fun you I can't believe you went
there why hey do you have uh why did you
go I'm not even kidding now bill I mean
we joke but that's too far acting thank
you do you have your try again do youal
do you have your do you have your
initials on your slippers I feel like
you're really like old Hollywood like
you have one of those phones that curls
around maybe the one that Jo R I wish I
was in all Hollywood because my I I love
those movies and I don't fit I don't fit
here I know you talk like you're from
the depression I
know Mr M America and all the all the
ships at see John L is at the Laugh
Factory at the Tropicana nice to see you
folks how are you this is this is a
character Eddie a gangster on the phone
with his mother but he has syphus of the
brain like Al Capone hello ma yeah it's
me Eddie Eddie
sposo SP p i m o zo o no Eddie your son
the goodlooking one no Eddie now listen
ma listen like you never listened before
do and are getting married yeah tonight
8:00 so how half father M lean will come
over about 7:45 all right I got to go I
got to go yeah well why'd you stick your
hand in it if it was boiling
all right I got to go I got to go yeah
what now you listen to me I don't care
who you are keep those filthy jokes to
yourself no I got to go I gotta go
yeah well what's Bill Bird doing now
well put that thing on and try slip it
in he's
crying
blood he says it
hurts no put it in his butt then now
what he
smiling
really listen John you can put all your
fetishes on me what are the question
yeah nice try Mirror Mirror Mirror what
do we at oh it's opposite day no you've
just gone with the anal thing quite a
bit on this show because the word but
it's just poop and butt it's just
funny I don't care how you are I'll do
this on they laugh sorry my lip has gas
it's like an eight-year-old that's what
you're like oh no my comedy is
sophisticated it's above I don't go for
the cheap laughs who are you talking
laughs blly blly blue who are you
talking to hope we don't go too far and
it ruins our friendship now did you have
another question no well I mean you're
at the
Tropicana you enjoy doing uh well I'll
be elsewhere and then I'm on the road
you know I play all the improv comedy
clubs and I delightful anyone in
particular game I'm going to be in Miami
in a couple couple of weeks in February
but you know it's just you know look at
their schedule and then I'm what else am
I doing I'm on that g the worst I've
ever you asked me to plug stuff you just
told them to look at this schedule I
think it's February
20 2nd or something the third 23rd to
25th listen I don't want to get a text
message from you saying that my podcast
pluging stuff U um I'll be at the Laugh
Factory you know February I think 15 16
to 17 and then I'm on a game show funny
you should ask it's just comedians
telling jokes what's the name of the
show funny you should ask Oh I thought
you were talking to me you talk like
that no that's funny funny you should
ask yeah well I'm a good actor you see
you can't tell the difference okay oh
and I'm doing an acting class oneon-one
with
you oh God I don't know if you'll ever
get it all right and what else no we're
not ending this I'm well was only
supposed to be a half hour well you'll
have to divide up into do shows what do
you mean a half hour I was told it was
an hour well that's what we said so
you'd shut up I wouldn't get up for a
half hour what do you mean you wouldn't
get up what time is it I I have yeah
it's 11 we've done an hour we've done an
hour you've got nowhere to go I have a
meeting oh children there in school
about trying to get better guests on my
podcast I got to tell you John you have
definitely been the low Point I've been
doing this podcast for a long time and
every time I think like wow that guest
just laid a [__] egg you are the new
Benchmark you know everything you do is
great including sucking I take that as a
compliment coming from
you you look like Al I knew that would
make you not say anything no I was just
wanted to say you look like Al
Delio well the guy the guy ran
Arnolds the guy who ran what Arnold's on
Happy Days oh you go yep yep yep yep yep
what if Gabby Hayes I don't know who
that is but that's hilarious good day he
was a actor played a
West had a big beard do you only watch
old [__] too like me remember this actor
Petty coo Junction well I want tell you
what's going on P I never saw Petty Co
Junction but I started watching
manx well my my may you might like this
story one of my best friends I grew up
with his dad was the tig Andrews Captain
Greer and Mod Squad did you ever watch
that
you know I can't find his best friend
was Mike Connor's I I
met trying to respond to your questions
I would watch Mod Squad if I knew where
to watch it I like that when I was a kid
watch it on your TV well is it no isn't
it what channel is it on I don't know
it's everything's on YouTube though
every they've downloaded
everything yes even when you had
hair young Bill Burr you you look like
Opie with the red hair and the freckles
that's a good one yeah I never heard of
that one that's a that's a [__]
reference by way was is Andy Griffith
your
dad did you sleep with Aunt B do you
know that's why I couldn't watch that
show why Aunt B just [__] annoyed the
[__] out of me no she annoyed me I could
you know what every time I I could
imitate her every time Andy that's my
one impression one of my Impressions I
do Andy oh Bill Burr's here Bill come
quick I'm horny oh God here comes Bill
Burr put it under my apron
delightful yeah that's you I like how
you go yeah the confidence afterwards
like it was amazing um well I have to do
that in case it didn't
work called despite your rudess did you
want to ask me any questions is this an
interview boring but go
[Music]
ahead I I have to it's 11 o' I have to
be somewhere at 11:30 no you
don't you are very fair with their
friend no wonder I'm here because it's
raining I just did an hour the podcast
is actually it's over and you're still
talking well I have John litz don't
leave them wanting more I have a
question for you this is leave them
wanting less all right but I I have a
real question for you this is real you
asked me what was my funnest uh thing I
funnest I'm not yes thank you what was
what what was the most performing what
was the most exciting thing you've done
what was it no I don't know you ask I'm
asking
you as a comedian or actor what was the
most where you were like oh man this is
It's too many to listen I had a [__]
great time last night at The Comedy
Store in the O it was just fun I was
trying new [__] out I had a great time
and then this [__] lady just started
yelling at me like saying what I was
saying wasn't true oh my you and you
ripped her I didn't I didn't really I
just kind of in the end I was just like
there was just no talking to her and I
just said I'm I'm sorry you're right do
me a favor text me or tweet me all the
books that you've read so I can attain
your level I just went like that I just
like she said what you were saying
wasn't right says it wasn't true wasn't
true oh so it was all the anti-semitic
stuff no about no it wasn't about your
people you could just you give a [__]
about anything but you
self
no they should have an entire Wing in
the Museum of Tolerance just about
you and on that and it has nothing to do
with Jewish people it's just how to
tolerate No you walk in you walk in and
it's a giant picture of you and it says
don't judge us all because of
him that you that's a great joke oh
thank you [__] Simon Simon there you
go is my own the [__] I'm sit back
and judging you because I'm older than
you because you actually really respect
me and you like me and this is your
[__] up way of showing it well why
can't why you got to be a [__] the whole
time you're the
[__] let me tell you something you dirty
rotten scoundrel um oh but what did you
really want to
say what did I want I'm rhymes with
Pew you know what's great about you
being Jewish is anytime anybody goes to
call you out about what a [__]
[__] you are you get to act like oh
it's you you you saying that about all
of us no I'm saying it about you I wish
you had lapels on right now so I could
just grab hold of both of them and just
tell you how much I don't like you and I
wish that you were funny I do my bones
that's how much I like you please please
and I go through special after special
after special dying to laugh wanting to
laugh praying to laugh just doesn't
happen though no really this is your
whole act really really I don't think so
really really that should be the name of
your next special
really your Earth is round really what
what should be what should be the name
of your you're probably a member of
the go ahead you'll come up with funnier
stuff than me sorry about
that I tried it was almost an hour I'm I
tried okay I can't get a Netflix special
too
funny you have a five I can't get one CU
I'm too funny how many do you have
10 I I don't I don't I don't sit around
counting how many specials I have oh CU
you have so many your you do no because
I move on to the next thing and try and
challenge myself and grow as a person un
likee
you and what would that be April 18th
doing my singing show at vibr comedy
sing with Randy Waldman your helicopter
instructor you know what I would go
there and Heckle you but I love Randy
too much he's the opposite of you he's a
sweetheart he's a caring man and he's a
nice man very nice man you know what I
don't have to [__] figure out how to
tolerate him and he's one of your people
you know what I just he's one of your
people that's right and he's a nice guy
and he's generous I just realized the
difference between you and me Talent
versus
no my everyone goes well how are you
funny I go all my characters and it's
character I'm I'm acting it's an
arrogant idiot but it's a character but
with you you actually are an arrogant
idiot wow we'll be right back you should
have rubbed your chin at the end of that
all right John you mean both of
them I would rub my chin I can't find it
you know why God gave you two hands so
you could rub bothin there you go you
can use that I'm way ahead you way ahead
of you all right what's bigger your
second chin or your ball sack at this
point which hangs lower I no I just wish
I would have brought my sunglasses cuz
that glare off your head is literally
burning my oh we get it on Bald no do
you get it
Jesus am I talking to you or is that
just a penis with
eyes oh by the way if anybody taking
this serious this is
all that we do and most here thing
here's the thing genus if I ever read
our tweets I mean that would be the end
of both of us I'm going to give you a
very big compliment not only you're a
great comedian your standup but you are
truly a great actor I don't know how you
did it but the the king of Staten Island
your acting was a you were amazingly
great like very rare that people can do
both
there's me and there's
you no it's true though it it's very
rare well I enjoy doing it like you're
acting on a deep sorry a level though he
you I mean like if you were just an
actor you'd be he's a great actor well I
got to be honest with you I'm I'm happy
that I'm not just an actor because for
whatever reason they don't want to pay
actors anymore it's [__] unbelievable
well no well the reason is when they
paid Mark Kon decided to pay Jim Carrey
20 million on Cable Guy and uh everyone
else like Schwarzenegger and they were
getting 15 so then they said well if
this is a terrible he's getting 20 then
then no I'm I'm telling you then then we
should be getting 2530 so the money that
extra 5 million that would go to actors
like me was gone the character what
happened they devalued everything
because they give every they you can
watch every movie now and every
documentary and every TV show for 20
bucks when you used to pay like 10 bucks
to see each movie that's why there's no
money that's what I think it's been like
devalued it's like [__] Spotify music
is now
free and then all the money goes to the
people that own Spotify I don't think it
has to do with Jim Carrey and they paid
him $20 million and his [__] movies
made like 200 million so they were plus1
180 why you staring at me like you're
[__] having a stroke I hope what I'm
sorry I I you are so articulate that my
brain shut down no it is because of that
you weren't if you weren't you weren't
working hug you weren't work what were
you doing uh 30 20 years ago were you
making movies I was inspired to get into
the business out of your ass I'm telling
you what happened I was inspired you
inspired me to get into this business I
was like if this ugly puss can get on TV
anybody can John love it everybody John
I love you to death I love you too Bill
yeah dude I have an unbelievable respect
for all of your work and I can't believe
that I even know you and I'm one of my
my favorite things in this [__]
business is texting back and forth with
you is you're you're a [__] Gem and
you're a sweetheart and he's an
unbelievably talented guy go see him
April 18th at vibr with the great Randy
Waldman go see him February 20s
something at the Laugh Factory in no 15
156 17 and where at the Tropicana at the
Tropicana then the next month April 2nd
they're closing theot
the Tropicana they're closing it they're
closing and they're ending on a high
note with the great John litz see that's
called a compliment you should [__]
try it sometime all right everybody
thank you so much for
listening your dog is [__] cute as
hell man I got to admit is that how you
meet the ladies you [__] dirt bag
when he was a puppy I did not now oh not
now what's he bringing in now
octogenarians huh what's what's the
oldest what what's the oldest you'd go
what's the oldest thing you bend over
90y old you'd Bend her over at Davenport
she was hot yeah yeah I go to nursing
homes hello ladies I don't want to
disrespect women out there but there's
you like younger men
there's all right John I love you thanks
you so much for coming in I know a thank
you Bill I'm looking forward to coming
back next week okay all right the great
John love it everybody and his dog look
out your dog's wagging his tail it's so
excited this bullshit's over all right
have a great weekend you guys
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday February 1st
2016 what's going on there you go the
first month of the year is out of the
way an old Billy booze
bag has been doing really well all right
last time I got
Hamond last time I got got hammered was
uh the last day verie was out here
visiting me whatever [__] day that
was it was like the second or third of
uh January and um I didn't drink for the
rest of the month other than the fact I
had eight beers left over from uh the
Rose Bowl so I just drank like one a day
for eight straight
days um always wanting a second forget
about a third and a ninth beer but I uh
just I just had one that was it so it's
not bad for me you know I went like 3
weeks without drinking then eight
straight days I only had one beer and
then yesterday I didn't have any beer in
the fridge I might have a Guinness left
but I didn't drink it so um you know we
were out here it was Sunday it was
[__] raining to beat the
band is that the [__] expression to
play the band I don't know what it was
[__] pouring out here for like
legitimately the almost the entire day
um which which is great we could
probably use about 90 more of those days
but it was good that that was happening
so um I just [__] stayed home didn't
do [__] last time I did Joe Rogan's uh
podcast he gave me some elk meat that he
had uh he [__] killed an elk he
murdered it premeditated the man got in
his car said I'm going to kill a [__]
elk but he didn't know which one so we
can only get him on second deegree
murder and I became an accessory to the
murder when I agreed to take some of the
carcass off his
head uh now he just gave me these two
like giant like softball sized things of
elk and they've been sitting in my
freezer so uh I heard the meats really
lean and that it could be a little gy so
I just looked up some recipes and there
was something there for like elk chili
and um so I uh I made that
yesterday and uh and it was [__]
delicious of course the lovely NE goes
out there and be like is this done this
doesn't look done this
doesn't I guess I'm just not used to
chili with this like consistency this
looks more like a Stew cuz it wasn't any
tomato paste in the recipe it was still
delicious it was definitely a little
more watery so she had to go out and go
[__] with the whole thing and I'm eating
the one that I made and I'm enjoying it
she just keeps in like in the other room
just kept going like yeah I don't know I
just think it need like more salt or
whatever then I was just like will you
shut up it's
fine [__] time I go out in the
kitchen she [__] nitpicks whatever
the hell it is that I'm making it's
[__] unbelievable she makes something
I eat it how it's good go out there and
go to the [__] spice rack you know
it's it's it's it's rude it's
rude so we got into it you know as we
always do right get into it a little bit
then she laughs tell me go [__] myself
and then she G gave me her version with
the tomato paste and you know what I
said I said oh yeah I see what you're
saying I like it you know that guess
what I really felt I felt the first one
tasted better she thickened it all up
with this [__] tomato paste and then
made it like sweeter and uh you know did
it to the whole [__] pot
so you know we had a giant partt of it
so I was like well I can handle what the
[__] she did to it if it's just mine I
got to eat the whole pot so I just
rolled with it just one of those times
you just sit quietly and you nod yeah
okay that's what you did over there all
right I'll approve that you
know anyways um underrated elk
meat got to throw it out there it's
[__] delicious so then we're [__]
sitting there right take my dog out
there's a little uh break in the
um in the in the weather so I take my
dog around the
block and uh blah blah blah blah blah
and I come back in and Nia's like hey
you know what want you want to have a
pot
cookie and I was like no I don't I got
the podcast to do I got some bills mail
and [__] I have to do she's like come on
it's [__] raining we're not going
anywhere this is a perfect day to have a
pot cook he's like I I don't like that
[__] gets me too [__] up I feel like
I'm hallucinating I don't want to do it
she goes no these are really mild these
are really mild I know everybody out
there who [__] consumes those things
right now is laughing no they're really
mild so I all right fine so I [__]
eat this
thing right
and it comes on really slow it's mellow
and I'm like all right I can deal with
this just sort of just be chilling out
and be relaxed and then all of a sudden
just [__] to the Moon Alice right was
like [__]
tripping not like literally but it was
just like you know I closed my eyes and
my feet would feel like they were 9
miles away from me you
know and uh that was it I took it in the
afternoon like around 4:00 by 5:00 that
was it the day was over so now here I am
I got a bunch of [__] to do and I'm
trying to cram this crap in there I
really I don't like
it um pthe head's idea of what mild is
is not you know now I'm sure I'm going
to get a bunch of
[__] get a bunch of [__] emails
from people going like this you want
this sativa [__] uh Asian infused
strain of weed man I just don't give a
[__]
right I mean I was like just I was
watching TV just dying laughing at
everything that [__] came on there my
wife made some cornbread with the chili
and I started doing like a cornbread
commercial you know hey guys what's
better than than a bowl of chili that's
right a nice piece of cornbread hi do
you know me of sure we all do I was just
doing that [__] and I was the funniest
[__] ever to me and Ne was looking at me
like what the [__] wrong with you I'm
like what do you mean what's wrong with
me you [__] drugged me
I swear to God you know what I think it
was I think the horror of me being
around for 24 hours with that weather
she got like cabin fever and she
literally drugged me because she was
able to handle it fine which is making
me think she took less and she was just
sitting there watching TV and I'm saying
all this [__] that's making me laugh and
she's just sitting there totally quiet I
like I go am I bombing over here she was
just like no no no I hear what you're
saying I'm just watching the show and
I'm like how are you that
[__] like I'm still a little [__]
up right now like 24 hours
later I don't know so anyways that's why
I like alcohol it slowly comes on I know
where it's going isn't like you grab a
beer and you're just I wonder what this
does what's the end no this this is a
mellow drunk and then all of a sudden
you get like [__] 20 times drunker
than you wanted to be I mean that can
start that can happen I guess with hard
stuff um
I I don't know I just feel like the
amount of [__] Edibles you have to
have to start to understand what they do
to you it's just not [__] worth it so
uh that was my one pot cookie for the
year but anyways I haven't had a cigar
since the eth um so I did it I'm trying
to be two cigar a month guy and I did it
in January I had one at the Rose Bowl
and I had one on the eth and then uh now
I got a whole [__] month ahead of me
so rather than smoking on the first you
know I'm just going to [__] chill
here for like a week to 10 days and I
thinkig I got two I can smoke really
just taking through my whole [__] uh
bad habit uh scheduled here aren't I um
oh speaking of cookies by the way I
bought two boxes of Girl Scout cookies
from this
lady you
know it's never the Girl Scout anymore
knocking on the door thank God thank God
with all the the uh to catch a Predators
they probably got sick of getting the
door [__] slammed in their face ding
dong you open the door hi I'm selling
girls got [__] slam the
door [__] yelling at your dog you saw
nothing happened so anyways um now
they're just sort of sold by adults as
far as I know so I got two boxes of
these [__] things and
um I just I finally realized the amount
of time that I've always felt like the
Girl Scouts made the cookies because
they were called Girl Scout cookies and
just somewhere maybe in the middle of
this country somewhere around Fort
Knox like the uh the United League of of
American us Girl Scouts has their
headquarters and they just had these
giant tubs where they just stirred up
cookie batter once a year and they got
him out and
um after finally thinking about it and
looking at the professional packaging
I'm I'm I'm going to go out on a limb
here and I and I'm going to say I don't
think I don't think any girl Scots make
any of those [__] [__]
cookies I think they [__] Outsource
it right it's probably made by children
Central
America they sit there crying how hard
they have to work knowing they're never
going to get a bite you know and then
one of them actually steals a cookie and
there's some psychotic disciplinary
action that's taken let's Google this
[__] huh shall we this is like the new
segment now just you know back in the
days you just talk now I'm actually
going to look it up here who
makes Girl Scout
cookies all right girl scout cookies all
right girl scout cookies are cookies
sold by Girl Scouts oh thank you thank
you Wikipedia Girl Scouts of the
USA or
gsusa as one of its major fundraisers
for local Scouts units members of the
Girl Scouts of America have been selling
cookies since
1917 girls who participate can earn
prizes for their effort [__] you that's
my name Alec Baldwin comes in and
screams at him all right the first
cookie
sales was by a scouting unit Missle the
mistletoe troop in Oklahoma in December
1917 at their local high school in 1922
Girl Scout magazine the American Girls
the American Girls suggested cookie
sales as a
fundraiser blah blah blah blah blah from
33 to 35 country-wise organ oriz cookie
sales grew with troops in Philadelphia
and New York City using the cookie
selling model so they're cooking their
own
ones World War II they sold
calendars in 1990 the National Council
limited the bakeries providing cookies
to just ABC bakeries a division of in in
baked
Foods oh wait I skipped over something
the 1950s three more cookie recipes were
added short breads peanut butter
sandwich and thin mint
the
classic that's like the Beetles Zeppelin
and the who of cookies six types of
cookies are being sold
Nationwide greater cookie sale due to
the baby boom generation they needed
more the Samoa was added in 75 all right
whatever so ABC Bakers was making in the
1990s and Little Brownie Bakers Little
Brownie Bakers a division of the kebler
company in 1998 cookie sale awards were
instituted with the 2005 trans fat
controversy the Girl Scouts moved to
make the cookies healthier and provide
nutritional information on the Box in
2009 the number of thin mitts Dosey Do
and tag Tagalongs in each box was
reduced why and lemon Chalet creams
became smaller because of the increasing
cost of ingredients and
transportation all right so they they're
they're they try to make them with less
uh less trans fats
here's 10 weird Girl Scout cookie facts
and then I'll get off this [__]
subject I I have dry mouth from that
[__] cookie last
night hey when they
legalize
like pot at a federal level do you think
that they'll actually have Girl Scout
like pot
cookies you know Jesus Christ that'll be
a field day what is happening to this
country I mean they're selling drugs all
right number one these cookies are older
than your grandmother that's not weird
it's not weird two you can make the
original recipe at home you can make the
original recipe of everything at home if
you know the
recipe if you feel like taking a trick
back in time and baking some boring
stuff oh this must be one of these
hipster sites where they're over
everything including making [__]
cookies you can try the authentic or
they actually like making the cookies
but they're anticipating being insulted
so what they do is they make fun of
themselves first so you can't authentic
original girl Girl Scout cookie recipe
it's not in the re recipe but they taste
better if you dress up as a girl scout
when you make them oh that's a little
internet joke only two companies make
the cookies Honey Boo Boo is banned from
selling
them Thin Mints are aren't just
delicious they're mandatory I don't know
what that means there is a cookie Queen
and she's a master
saleswoman oh there's unsanctioned Girl
Scout cookies weed strain of course Girl
Scout cookies used to cost less than a
quarter everything cost less there was a
cookie shortage during World War II of
course not every cookie made the
grade ah Jesus that was disappointing
all right can I apologize for wasting
the last [__] 15 minutes of your life
talking about Girl Scout
cookies um did anybody watch the NHL
allall star game [__] three on three
hockey dude it was actually pretty
entertaining but not quite as exciting
as I thought it was going to be cuz no
one was going to take the body dude but
it was still cool and obviously seeing
John Scott score a couple of goals
that's [__] hilarious that the NHL
didn't want him in there after all the
money that they've made on fighting and
all the [__] that a goon goes through
you know the fact that the fans liked
him enough to elect him into the game
right then he gets [__] it sit down
with a minus and they told him not to
show up then he blogged about it like a
seventh grade chick and everybody went
dude what the [__] and then he was there
and then he scored two goals was like a
Hollywood [__]
movie hey any non hockey fans did you
actually sit down and watch the All-Star
game it's everything that you would have
liked huh a zillion [__] goals no
fighting nothing physical people smiling
after R running into one another was it
dumb down enough for you there [__]
hoop heads
um I actually only watched the first
period it appeared like the first period
was only like 10 minutes long is that
true or was I under the influence of a
pot
cookie
um but anyways oh exciting news here
exciting news for me um I'm actually
doing a gig in Cheyenne
Wyoming now Wyoming is the last state
that old [__] Billy redface has never
performed in and at this point um I will
have performed in all all [__] 50
states and uh that being the fact that I
don't know I have a little that
OCD right is that what it is no I don't
know what it is I just like you know at
first I was like you know what I'm going
to go to every baseball stadium then it
be immediately goes I'm going to go to
every [__] stadium that exists you
know so if I start doing standup and
then it become oh I did I've done three
states and immediately I have to do
every state and then it becomes uh I
have to do every continent you know
except for like Antarctica or like
places that don't want me
right but anyways I'm going to be uh I'm
going to be in Cheyenne W I'm going to
be first of all I'm going to be in
Danver Rocky Mountain High and please
don't bring me any [__] pot cookies
all right I don't enjoy the high I don't
okay I I just it's too much on the 12th
and 13th I believe the uh 12th and 13th
is Wyoming and Denver or Denver Wyoming
I don't know which one and then the 14th
is Valentine's Day and that's of course
when uh young people go out cuz they're
not smart enough to realize that uh that
you can say I love you on any day of the
year you know what's a great day to go
out go out on like the
17th you know or the 16th or the 19th or
the 21st don't go out right before go
out after go out after I say this every
[__] year you know look at this the
Super Bowl this year is on the seventh
and the [__] Valentine's Day is on
the 14th now those are two absolutely
absolute [__] show days now obviously if
your own [__] football team is
playing in the Super Bowl you know you
just you're going to want to watch it
with a couple other fans
right however that doesn't mean that you
going you go to one of those [__] show
[__] Super Bowl parties so like I
said as always take the [__] game Let
It Go for a good 90 minutes then you
come in you sit down you blow through
all the commercials you blow through the
[__] halftime show fast forward
through all of that [__] and then uh
when the game really starts getting down
to it you know you you're caught right
up you'll catch up in like the beginning
of the uh the fourth quarter then you
can just kind of watch it in real time
it's [__] perfect and'll blow you
whole
afternoon oh [__] sorry guys no more pot
cookies for me
um and then the uh on the 14th same
thing just wait like 2 three days after
when you can get a [__] reservation
you can go to the restaurant you want to
go to and they haven't jacked the prices
up through the [__]
roof
um and then you're done
right here's a good one right cuz guys
we usually don't get [__] on Valentine's
Day so uh I suggest don't get your wife
[__] either just take her out to dinner
and [__] leave it at that and if
she's like I thought you were going to
get me something else just be like well
did you get me something else and when
she's like no you be like all right well
I paid for
dinner that's it and that guarantees
that you'll be in a [__] awful fight
on Valentine's Day how you like that see
what I'm staring staring you
towards um for the life of me billberg
coming to Cheyenne Civic
Center 21 the [__] are you talking
about that can't be
right Bill bur will perform at the
Cheyenne Civic Center in Cheyenne
Wyoming on Thursday February 11th all
right so then on the 12th I must be in
Denver is that
right Jesus Christ Bill how do you why
don't you [__] know your own goddamn
schedule Denver I had to go skiing when
I'm out there you know I ski once every
10 years I really should take a lesson
cuz that that is just the uh blow you
[__] yeah the 12th all right so the 11th
Thurs
I'm in Wyoming and February 12th I'm in
Denver oh that's how it is very nice so
there you go the Cheyenne Civic Center
you know they always have [__] rodeos
and [__] there right what goes on there
Toby Keith Cheyenne Civic Center Civic
Center it's be like some old ABA
Building
images Jesus Christ Christ look at
cheyen this looks like a [__] Opera
plays there an opera Bill an
orchestra um the Cheyenne Civic Center
he going to Cheyenne
Wyoming what are some of the great
things that happened in Wyoming over the
years
huh only thing you always hear is bad
stuff isn't that place with uh where
they tied that poor kid cuz he was gay
to the fence until he
died this isn't good they don't have any
sports tapes the [__] am I going to
Wyoming
for Wyoming isn't this where like Ted
Turner can ride his horse all over the
place and be like I own that I own that
too get off of
there or I'll take you out of out of
your basic cable package take my my my
[__] TV out of
here um don't ever start any [__] with
Ted turny and Wyoming all
right cuz he's going to come in a arrest
you and then he's going to be the judge
and he's going to throw you in he owns
the whole [__] State doesn't
he I believe he does
right I don't know anyways let's get to
the [__] reads here for this week old
Billy all over the
place all right what do we got here the
first read oh look who's back everybody
sher's
berries will split it up um you know I
was actually debating watching the Super
Bowl by myself and doing a little bit of
commentating during the game you guys
seem to enjoy that um maybe I'll do
commentating during the shittiest most
boring Parts but then I'd have to sit
and watch it like whoever's
opening and I know Sting's playing the
halftime show and as much as I want to
go see him and and Vinnie kudas on my
bucket list like that's not the right
band I halftime at the Super Bowl
huh Every Breath You Take
in every move you make he's going to
have to go more uptempo [__] what do you
think Sting's going to play from his
repertoire
huh anything of 10 summer
Tales but that's not the queen of my
heart no that's not the
shape of my heart right you can't play
that
song
what song was
that [__] song was that then there
was a song about the
brothers wonder that he was a coward
none of that is going to play well he'll
probably play
synchronicity right you had a football
game that Stadium Rock to just sit there
[Music]
going right bunch of old baby boomers
singing along bunch of kids going that's
not dubstep
um yeah dude I want to fast forward
through all that [__] yeah I'm thinking
about maybe commentating on some of that
stuff I'll just do like uh maybe I'll
just do like 3 minutes of the game you
know cuz I think it'll get boring after
a while you know um at least if I'm
getting get bored of myself I would
think that you guys would get bored
know um all right let's plow through
here so I don't have any booze in the
fridge so I'm just I guess the month of
uh I sort of half ass committed to this
like not
boozing is that a bad thing the [__] is
the other oh there it is sorry
um talked about everything pot cookie
raining out here shine oh I haven't been
on the [__] road in weeks so um I
might be doing wink wink oh I am doing a
show this week that's right I'm doing
the uh Dean Del Ray Del re at the LR oh
Jesus um a night of comedy and
rock uh Dean Del re's 50th birthday
party he's gonna have um you know he's
gonna have Joe Rogan Chris deyah myself
myself um I know there's a couple other
Comics uh red band's going to be down
there and I want to
say I want to say there's maybe one
other comic and then after that um Dean
Del re is going to front a
band um that will include the likes of
Rudy Saro Dave Kushner Dave Lombardo
uh Tracy guns gilby Clark all these rock
stars and he's going to sing the entire
Highway to Hell album and uh old Billy
redface might sit in for a song or two
but it's going to be a great night you
can get tickets at uh golden voice.com
and also um I might be doing a uh a
surprise show somewhere locally cuz I
got to run my hour so when I go to
Cheyenne Wyoming when I get out there
check out the
spread I want to make sure they going to
be on my game I don't want people in the
crowd being like what the [__] man you
made us wait to be number 50 for that
[__] walking around the John Denver
[__] sheep coats right that the Sheep
lining Rocky Mountain High
Colorado Bill we don't talk like that
talk like this that's what wyom is all
about I'm going to the capital man um do
they have open carry in Wyoming you know
I made such a big deal about open carry
in uh Texas and uh turns out that
they've had it in Oklahoma for years and
there hasn't been a [__] problem so
um that's kind of a non
story and then I think that kind of adds
to the touristy Vibe of going to Texas
and seeing people walking around with
holsters you know maybe you can see have
somebody have a [__] shootout over
like a parking parking space a duel
right draw
oh
um yeah worst case scenario just a bunch
of people that I don't know die which is
uh considering with global warming and
overpopulation I think it's a good thing
I think they should have open carry
uh they should have everywhere everybody
strapped it would probably actually end
up being safer when you think about it
cuz I know like New York City for as
much as everybody talks about how
dangerous it was uh I just found on the
on the Subways where where all of a
sudden you were riding in the car with
[__] everybody it's all mixed up
there there was a certain level of
heightened courtesy cuz you didn't want
to have a [__] problem you know it's
the subway it's New York City you can
get mugged you can get the [__] kicked
out of you so people [__] minded
their business so I think if you had a
whole state of everybody walking around
with a gun on their hip you know
somebody cut you off in traffic you know
you
know yeah I could yell you [__]
[__] but what if you start shooting
at me yeah it's okay go ahead buddy I
mean I have a gun too but you know what
if I miss and you don't by all means go
in front of me you know like if
somebody's being weird to you and you're
at one of those ATMs that's on the
outside of a building yeah it's a very
nervous moment for you but if you're in
your car and that same person cut you
off you're I [__] kick the [__] out
of you you [__] dick you're all tough
in your
car which can lead to road rage now if
you know that that guy has a gun he
could just simply you know point it out
the side of his car and just shoot in
the general direction of your car you
figure at the very least he's going to
hit the radiator right you have that
steam coming up like in every [__]
movie just a good old boy
right you're probably going to mind your
[__]
business maybe that's the secret to
ending all wars everybody's strapped you
have the gun out you just walk in and
every time you just walk you just the
gun's already pointed at somebody how
you doing I'm doing good how are you all
right that's that's great yeah know keep
the conversation short and
sweet I think I just solved all our all
of our problems right everybody strapped
with a loaded gun out pointed at
somebody safety
off cause you to be more relaxed you
know although you couldn't have safety
off cuz then when people fell asleep you
know it's like falling asleep while you
know smoking you're can light your bed
on fire you might squeeze off around
which doesn't even make sense right cuz
you got to put pressure on it unless
you're having one of those dreams you
know you one of those dreams where
you're falling or somebody just gives
you a leg sweep sweeps your legs for
whatever reason and you you're [__]
tense up maybe then then you shoot
yourself in the
foot I bet podiatrists would be all I
bet they're all four open carry you know
the foot doctors all right you want me
to do some reads for this week here
let's get into it
um
where are we come on Bill for God's
sakes oh I was on the right one to begin
with oh hey by the way does anybody know
like when a [__] for whatever reason
you download an album off of iTunes and
then for whatever reason it just sort of
disappears off of your phone and then
[__] reappears because you haven't
hooked it up to the computer you know
what I mean with your phone and that
makes it legitimately on your phone
rather than just going through the air
or whatever the [__] going on
right you know cuz you got the WiFi on
and then the Wi-Fi shuts off and then
the album disappears so then you're old
like me so you download it again and
then you got that album and then the the
the the first one comes back and now you
got doubles how do you get rid of the
other one I've gone into my iTunes and
I've gone to delete it but on my phone
it's still in doubles I don't know how
to do it so the song ends and then it
replays again it plays everything twice
that happened me with Van Hal in 1984
and that Nas album IL Matic and um as
much as I love both of those albums I
don't need both songs to play twice how
do I get rid of the other one if anybody
can tell me I would really appreciate it
all
right okay Kanye situation hey Bill
red-blooded American male here who heard
about the Kanye situation and was scared
shitless I'm not going to disclose
whether or not I enjoy what he was
accused of enjoying uh parenthesis if
you don't know the story his ex Amber
Rose implied on Twitter that he enjoyed
a finger in his ass actually it was
fingers
plural yeah I didn't hear about this
[__] story and it may me feel good as
a human being that I was somehow out of
the loop of this [__] news he said
this scared me because it doesn't matter
what you're into if an ex says [__] like
that you're going to get
branded um sir you sound like your ex
put a vase in your
ass
anyways he goes it's how Urban myths
about Geral get started unless you're
Fearless jimm Norton and you can say
something like that with the smile on
your face on the Airways it's a pretty
tough situation to be in how does a man
like Kanye deal with
that
uh I I don't
know I I went I started to read it but I
don't it
just I don't if it is true I don't give
a [__]
it's not it's really none of my business
but for what I could tell from the
article he was talking [__] about her
now had if she had half her hand up his
[__] ass at some point it's probably
not a smart idea if he's sensitive about
that part of his sexuality to be talking
[__]
right which makes me kind of believe him
that it didn't
happen because you figure if she had
that over him if she was walking around
with him like a sock puppet right that
he wouldn't go around talking [__] about
her I don't
know I got to be honest it's one of
those things that I I legitimately feel
is none of my [__] business and uh
whether it's true or not doesn't make me
look at Kanye one way or the other I
mean I don't give a [__] I don't give a
[__] what the guy does and I also think
uh I don't think you walk around talking
[__] about someone you used to go out
with didn't work out [__] grow up
you're already married you found
somebody else leave him alone
right I don't look I don't know what
happened but all I know he was if if
it's true that he was talking [__] about
her I probably should stop saying
talking [__] when we're talking about a
finger up your ass
um you know I haven't said all that it's
[__]
[Music]
hilarious um
you know I would think that there's a
lot of rival rappers right now trying to
write down words that rhyme with the
phrase fingers up your
ass
uh lingers in the class with fingers up
your ass I'm sorry I don't know there
there's got to be something that they're
coming up with that's an easy one
too if I was if I was a rapper and
somebody said that my ex put fingers up
my ass all I would be thinking was like
God damn it why didn't she say rect
them at least make it difficult to rhyme
something wct them check them you check
them fingers up you wreck them no
fingers check
them they're all clean going up you
wreck them sorry
[Music]
um
anyways um
classes I like that how that's 100% sent
on him what about her with her stinky
fingers now Jesus Christ you got to go
with the fist bump now when you go with
into uh when you run into Amber give it
the old elbow you want to stay away from
that get a [__] tetanus
shot funny if she you shook her hand and
then all of a sudden you just started
[__] talking [__] about yourself the
way Kanye does um all right
classes uh in high school uh hello you a
rangang looking [__] I guarantee
that this guy is the ug [__] I
really find that people uh people who
trash the way I look the most especially
on Twitter never have like their uh
never have their picture I don't look
like an orangutan do I they're [__]
older they look like old people um in a
house coat uh I am a senior in high
school yeah like a kid oh you're
probably 18 at this point you're Punk uh
this may seem childish to talk about but
I been thinking about dropping one of my
classes this class is music theory AP
and I'm a straight B student student so
I'm no genius I had talked to my teacher
and guidance counselor who both said it
was fine to drop it music theory being a
unique
class what was that appendix right there
at the end there that didn't make that
was all part of that
sentence anyways recently I came into
school thinking uh that was this [__] I
I came into school thinking that this
[__] was over and I wouldn't have to
take the class anymore only to have the
assistant principle of my school tell me
that I would not be able to drop at that
this point I'm frustrated because I'm
very unhappy in the class and the only
one separating me from dropping the
class is my prick of an assistant
principal should I sack up and finish
the rest of the year or should I stand
up from my case and become a stubborn
prick in the process the class gives me
anxiety and I'm not really into music
anymore I'm thinking about picking up a
second English class if the principal
doesn't let me drop the class I would
probably end up skipping it every day
because I hate the class that [__]
much am I in the wrong any advice would
be great Bill thanks and go [__]
yourself um oh when I was a kid when you
went to high school you couldn't drop
classes that happened in college you're
a senior it's
February don't you get out in like the
middle of
May uh um and if you're transferred you
have to make up the first two semesters
or whatever the [__] it
is September October November
and December and January worth of [__]
in your second English class I just
tough it
out it's music theory I mean that sounds
boring as
[__] um but whatever just tough it
up I I that's what I would do I
mean I mean I would rather tuck up tough
I maybe I'm just speaking about myself
personally but I'd rather tough out
music theory than to take another
[__] English class but that's
me yeah dude just [__] tough it
out what's it giving you anxiety for
it's it's a music theory teacher it's
not like they're going to be
like it's like the football coach is
teaching it is
he yeah [__] it tough it out that seems
like a class that even if you just
halfway pay attention you can at least
get a c right I don't know dude this
[__] this [__] hangover from this
goddamn cookie I mean I fell asleep last
night at like 6:00 I slept for like 12
[__]
hours I'm still exhausted all right
being stung by
[__] hey Billy big Freckle
balls I love how you guys think I Sun my
nuts uh your last podcast touched on
being stung by spiders and [__] and you
touched on
stingrays uh those [__] that killed
Steve Irving no no no no no no no no no
he [__] with them and the thing felt
like it had to uh defend itself all
right I'll tell you right
now the the rejoicing that Wildlife did
overall when the crocodile hunter got
killed I mean the level of stress that
he brought every animal that he came
into contact with all see he's ing up he
doesn't like that the thing is in fear
for its [__]
life and you're going up and you're
[__] with the things you know in your
little [__] booty shorts anyways he
goes I'm Canadian and I spent 5 minutes
in an American ocean and was stung by a
Stingray well all of your oceans are
American too you live in North America
we're all Americans but I guess once you
say you're
Canadian I'm United okay I'm a Canadian
I spent 5 minutes in an American ocean
was stung by a stingray it felt like a
hot nail being driven through my foot
and the pain went up and up for hours it
was the most painful thing I've ever
experienced uh let that be a lesson to
all the listeners that stingrays are not
something to be [__] with uh nothing
can describe that pain it was insane
love the podcast [__] you and Boston
because they win so [__]
always because they win so [__]
always
um yeah well you
know this is the thing we're not
supposed to be in the
ocean okay I'm going to say that
again we're not supposed to be in the
ocean we can't breathe in there we can't
see what's beneath us we're completely
vulnerable when we go in there we're not
supposed to be in there that Stingray
has evolved to [__] up things that
belong in the ocean all of which are way
bigger and way faster generally speaking
some giant fish goes to
[__] kill the stingray it's got to
have enough juice in its shank to make a
shark go away I would think so yeah you
come walking
in you [__] pink feet come walking in
there if you're white right you go in
there and you did just yeah it's
over surp I'm surprised they don't got
enough juice to kill
you cuz I know Steve Irving what
happened to him is he got stabbed in the
[__]
hat I think it punctured his
heart what are the odds of
that I wonder what his [__] last
thoughts
were he's probably ah
really [__] sting
right or is he just thinking ow let me
just pull this out I'm sure that'd be oh
no oh that's artery blood all right love
the podcast go [__] your you know what's
funny somebody in Australia is going to
be offended that I'm actually [__]
talking like they haven't thought about
this [__] wasn't it like 10 years
ago what is the statute of limitations
when you uh deliberately go and [__]
with a uh Stingray and get killed by it
that it's
um that you can't keep talking about all
right beer drinking contest advice dear
Billy
beerbong I'm a big fan man I listened to
your podcast for a couple of years now
and I had the chance to see you verie
and botnik at the Chicago Theater Great
show so I've been roped into a beard
beer drinking Olympics parenthesis for
charity by a buddy of mine and being
that I'm an old [__] not quite where you
are I'm 38 I was wondering if you have
advice in terms of longevity backstory
on me I'm a
Canadian I'm a Canadian pocket square
wearing Habs fan I know [__] me right I
don't give a [__] as long as you have a
sense of humor about yourself that can
really Hammer them back beer is my first
choice when I drink as I assume is yours
what would you do to get ready for
something like this thanks and go [__]
yourself
um well you got to I would
think aren't there going to be different
events you know there's got to be
drinking beer there's got to be drinking
hard
stuff is it all just going to be beer
drinking wait a second I was wondering
if you have any advice in terms of
longevity all right as far I thought you
meant how to how to live long you mean
how to hang in there
um well if it's a beer drinking contest
then I would just drink hard stuff
leading up to
it you know a couple of beers and have
like your shots too you know I don't
know build up your tolerance this
doesn't seem like this is a responsible
thing for me to be telling you to do I
would be I would just go there and have
a good time that's what I would do and I
wouldn't try to win a medal you don't
want to be the guy that wins that the
guy wins that going to have like [__]
rosacea on the side of his face from
boozing you know it's going to look like
[__] WC Fields you don't want to be
the guy that can win that contest test I
would say just go there have a good time
you know and uh stop short of being the
guy that [__] pukes all over
everybody that would be my
advice uh all right let me do the last
reads here really quickly and then I'll
do the last question alrighty mercifully
it is
ended um all right let's get back to uh
I got one more read here and then I got
to wrap this [__]
up it's time for me to go all right
dating in the workplace hey AKA no
Jesus Billy [__] boy
Burr oh hey by the way I finished uh the
second season of Top boy I highly uh I
highly recommend it um all right there's
a
lady in my workplace that I have a huge
crush on but I [__] everything up by
drunkenly telling her best friend at a
company holiday party that I had a crush
on on her I say [__] up because I know
how females communicate I might as well
have just walked up to the girl I had a
crush on and told her I know from a past
job that dating in the workplace [__]
everything else up at work and told
myself I'd never do it again but for
some reason my brain couldn't say no to
this girl anyway I know this girl knows
I like her from her best friend and it
made our work Dynamic awkward just
because when we interact now both of us
feel like we have to fulfill some sort
of
role well you should just walked up to
him and says hey I got a little drunk I
said some things to uh your girlfriend
uh that you know I should have said to
you I can't say that that's too
forward oh the office just makes it
creepy you can't lean on anything as
you're talking to her you might as well
just be standing there rubbing your
balls ah this a situation one day I said
[__] it and half asked her out to an art
museum but she had friends in town said
she couldn't what pisses me off is that
I used to hang out with my co-workers
and this girl every now and then now no
no one invites me to hang out when they
do uh background on the company it's
under a 100 people and we're all in our
20s for the most part uh what's the best
way to pursue this girl in this
situation and how do I mentally handle
the fact that it's affected my ability
to hang out with my co- my other
co-workers I really want closure to this
thing whether it be a date whether I
date her or she tells me she's not
interested I don't care at this point I
really don't like the tension at work
thanks and go [__] yourself yeah which
says to me you don't really even like
this
girl like I just want to ask her out and
get rid of the tension either she says
yes or she says no I really don't give a
[__] at this moment this is what you do
this is what you do sir you just just
[__] blow it
off just blow it off you don't give a
[__] just act normal around her all
right then she'll be going like oh he
doesn't give a [__] and then she'll
probably end up being interested in you
cuz that's how they [__] work all
right don't don't hang out with the
people you work with [__] someone you
don't work with you need to create a
Social Circle outside of work the people
at work should be the people you see
Monday through Friday okay and then once
Friday see you later guys take it easy
what are you doing I'm getting the [__]
away from you right then you go out you
can do your [__] black tiar heroin or
whatever the [__] you want to do and
then there's no awkwardness at The
copier all right you already said you
you you you [__] somebody that you
worked with before and how that made
your last job awkward yet here you go
again and for some reason you're not
even in a relationship yet and it's
already [__] up your Co your
uh just your your interaction with your
co-workers yet you want to pursue this
thing dude I I would just Let It
Go just Let It Go and
uh listen you want to [__] somebody at
work don't try and [__] them all all
right just come in with a big smile on
your face on Monday and you know nobody
knows what the [__] you did and they're
all hanging out with each other they're
all gossiping with each other and
eventually they're going to be gossiping
about you hey I wonder what he does
what's up with his exciting life you
know and you're coming in looking like
you're out there banging away and
[__] having a great time going out in
the town eventually one of these broads
is going to be [__] interested enough
and then you know what your dumb ass is
going to [__] her and then it's going to
be awkward again can't do it dude you
got to you got have a [__] your
social you're [__] and you're
drinking and all that has to be outside
of
work um unless it's a guy okay it cannot
be you cannot [__] hang with women
that you work with you can't do it CU
eventually your dick's going to make you
say something stupid something's going
to happen where that's going to get in
the [__] way and it's just going to
be a big be a big goddamn problem uh
same thing don't hang out with your boss
either hang out with somebody that's on
your [__] level and even then dude I
wouldn't I wouldn't hang out don't hang
hang out with people you work with you
know something always ends up happening
maybe you do something dumb and then
your buddy can't keep his [__] mouth
shut you know and then it gets to
somebody and then that you're up for
your your your review you don't get as
much money you get passed over it's
[__] stupid you're in your 20s you're
going to make a you're going to make a
bunch of [__] mistakes so don't do it
with the people you work with all right
have I said that enough
times all right haven't said
that um you want my Super Bowl
pick um I actually like the Broncos with
the points if they get in
six and don't listen to me because I
don't know anything about the Broncos
coach but I know bill bich with pton
Manning and that defense could figure
out a way to uh beat the Carolina
Panthers and I know a lot of you guys
are thinking well that defense and that
coach and pton Manning just beat your
Patriots and Bill bich it's like well he
didn't have the team you know
um my only concern is that Denver's
defense isn't as good as it looked
against the Patriots because uh we had
that swiss cheese [__] offensive line
we had injuries all that year and
Carolina looks really healthy their
offensive line looks really healthy so
uh I don't know I think that [__]
that I actually said earlier where I was
making fun of those analyst those
analysts is actually what I think Denver
better hope they win the toss and I
would say take the ball rather than
deferring it and hopefully you march
down the field score seven give them a
three and out I think I literally think
that they and then need to score again
go up 10
nothing this is my keys to the game
Denver win the toss they need to go out
there and somehow get it done and choose
heads if it's going to be heads Tails if
it's going to be Tails then they got
to take the [__] ball Ram it down
their [__]
throats yeah just obvious [__] nice time
consuming
drive and uh establish the
Run um I think pton can do all right
against their defense if they if they uh
you
know if he has the [__]
time see there's no way to say really
Bill what if he doesn't have the time
does that make it more difficult this is
really hard this is really it's really
hard to say something that isn't cliched
um
my my concern as a Broncos fan is that P
the Panthers get the ball they March
right down the field and they score
because what's his face pton Manning is
is gloom and doom guy that guy gets that
look on his face pton face is what me
and my family used to call it where he
just he just purses his lips and he
starts looking down field shaking his
head as he takes his [__] chin strap
off after he yet another three and
out that's the that's the the head space
Panthers want to get him in
if he gets into that he gets into that
why isn't everybody as good as me
mindset uh it's [__] over so in order
to keep him happy I'd say that they got
to score ear back to that
again ah Jesus maybe I'll come up with
something on Thursday there you go
everybody I take the Broncos in the
points I take six points [__] it cuz
every [__] out there's going to take the
Panthers every [__] out there's going
dude the Panthers are going to [__]
destroy them that's when you want to go
the other way because what that means
that every [__] [__] out out there is
going to put money on the Panthers which
means the line will keep going up cuz
Vegas is one to get is going to want to
get money on both sides of the
ball thank you Bill like we didn't know
that I'll [__] you I'll talk to you guys
on Thursday go [__] yourselves and um
don't [__] anybody you work
with